thanks a lot Michael for the
introduction so I don't have to worry
about people googling right now where
the University of Queensland is we know
it's in Australia so I'm gonna talk
about the essence of my talk would be a
little bit maybe different than all the
previous talks in that I'm interested in
randomness and randomized approach but
not necessarily to see how I can solve
the problem more efficiently but rather
as it relates to me being able to
understand why a method does what it
does or why model works so more in the
sense of understanding as opposed to
efficient solution so you know it's a
program on data science and if you ask
anyone what is a what is data science
you probably hear tons of different
definitions it's really not sure no one
knows what the data science is but you
know you can see a lot of buzzwords
coming around and everybody looks at
data science from their own perspective
right some look at it as a way that I
got a big data said I want to work with
it the other one is that where the data
is coming from the interpretive results
and so on and so forth but regardless of
where you're coming from hopefully
everybody agrees that data science
whatever it is lie somewhere in the
intersection of computer science domain
scientists to whatever it is that they
do and the math or or statistics and
traditionally maybe the problems were
initiated by the people in the domain
because they had the day
but they didn't know how to analyze it
and probably they tried to approach
computer scientists because they had the
algorithms
mr. decisions and mathematicians had the
models and then mathematicians and
computer sciences worked together to to
try to solve these more efficiently now
I was aware of you know the existence of
the domain scientist if you will and I
was educated personally as a computer
scientist so I really underappreciated
an appreciate enough the role of
Statistics in understanding data
scientific questions and a couple of
recent results I've developed a special
appreciation for for the role of
randomization is randomized analysis and
the statistics in answering data science
questions and these are going to be the
examples that I'm going to share with
you from my perspective hi I approach
these things yes I mentioned at the
beginning so you know there's data you
offer often are given some kind of a
model either it's explicitly given to
you or by making some assumptions or the
typical at topper algorithms you using
you implicitly make some assumptions
about the models or you work with models
implicitly and the talks that we've been
hearing and most often probably most
probably the in the rest of the workshop
as well mostly be focused on randomized
methods that how you efficiently solve
will compute with these morals but the
interest of this particular target may
be some other ones as well is that to
use randomized ideas to understand why
these models work or why they don't and
I will do this hopefully try to get to
two sets of examples one is the
application of randomized analysis your
understanding certain aspects of deep
learning and the other one would be the
same but in in the context of graph
analysis and the first paper is entirely
the work of my PhD student Grasso
all the credit goes to him and all the
criticism goes to me or Marcus more me
but this is the first one about the deep
learning and the second one I hope I get
a chance to talk about it as you can see
I didn't put it up here because I didn't
want you to freak out and see tons of
these circles up there and if I get to
it I'll try to talk about it if not no
big deal I just wanted to say a shout
out to today people actually made this
also work happen this is the grass keith
was here a couple days ago he gave a
talk on this in a reading group so
hopefully some of you have seen if I get
don't get to it that way okay alright so
deeply regardless you know how you
interpret deep learning or Norrell it
and so on some people want to turn it a
little bit six year than it is and say
you know it's come from the brains
trying to model the neurons in the brain
and so on and so forth and some
mathematicians also make it probably a
little bit more simpler than what it
should be and say ah it's just you know
composition of bunch of nonlinear
functions and it's nothing else and well
I agree with the second a second
perspective we're yet in order as a
mathematical object is just nothing but
a composition of nonlinear composition
of functions where you put a I hope I'm
not blocking the view but where you put
in a signal into the network you sort of
weighted by certain weight matrix you
put it through a non-linearity you do it
repeatedly a certain number of times and
then you end up having an output and it
can do these you know there's no reason
why there's three years it could be you
know 30 or 300 and so on and deep refers
to these three approaching three hundred
and three thousand and this is the
revolution some people refer to as a
deep learning revolution because if you
look at the progress in in machine
learning in terms of the accuracy of the
prediction say for example
classification error rate on this
typical data set canonical data set
image that you see that the winners
across the years progress
need an oral net that they used they had
one thing in common and that's that the
the the depth start going up and up and
up and up and the more depth they had
the better results at the end of it they
managed to to get and this became sort
of like a game of you know let me just
push the boundaries and have a deeper
you know deeper deeper net to the point
where you know there's cartoons about it
that you know yeah you know this is just
like you know I was doing well until
this guy added a couple more layers and
couple of GPUs and managed to beat me on
imagenet now it's my turn to do that
again and you can also see the
correlation if you superimpose this on
that you'll see pretty much the same
pattern in terms of the number of
registrations and paper submissions and
nips so depth this is literally most
often is depth related but that is depth
is driving the the popularity and the
also success of machine learning to some
degree but you know to level that it's
been quotes that you know you can do
anything almost if not the best option
to do it it's gonna be the second best
option to do anything you want with Nora
let as long as it's deep enough and
which is the reality and but you know
this is is it all rosy I mean so why
don't we just keep tagging onto it
you know 3,000 layers and just solve
everything we want I turned out that
beyond computational constraint suppose
you could throw all the GPUs in the
world at it
beyond computational constraints there
are other inherent issues with
increasing depth and I'm going to touch
upon a few of these some of them you
already have seen it many times and
they're actually textbook stuff and a
couple of them are a little bit more new
in terms of what could wrong go wrong
when I have a deep mob so I'm sure most
of you have heard of vanishing an
exploding gradient problem this was a
classical problem that was
observed a few decades ago few years ago
I'm not sure exactly when but at the
outset of you know people trying to get
layers and tag on layers the immediate
problem was the vanishing or exploding
gradient problem if you have seen this
before I apologize that I have to repeat
but if not essentially the idea is this
so I have say here three two hidden
layers one input layer and one output
layer it's a simple network and for
simplicity also assume that my loss
function is just a quadratic so I put an
X here I get a prediction of what Y
should be that's why it's Y hat and I
have some labels or some whatever it is
and I compare yeah as it relates to l2
more right if I want to compute it I
want to find the optimal weight that
minimizes this objective I have to run
some kind of an gradient based algorithm
so I have to be able to compute the
gradient of this cost function with
respect me every one of these double
users and these double used it without
this subscript essentially is all these
double use tagged on in a long vector
matrix doesn't matter really okay so
let's look at what is the gradient of
the cost function with respect to the
weight say layer L that takes in the ice
neuron of the previous layer 2jh neuron
of the next layer right so there is all
these connections and I'm trying to
compute the gradient in the output with
respect to the input all right it turns
out to be you know if you go through
this back board back propagation
algorithm and so on it comes out to be
the product of two terms doesn't matter
what they are the important thing is
that one of these terms depends at the
derivative of these Sigma's here they're
known as activation function the
derivative of the activation function at
certain point now if your activation
function has a lot of flat regions then
this is going to be very small if not
zero and you see that in order to
compute this I also need to compute
other quantities from the layers after
this layer which all of these also
include terms
like that yes it's okay
I quite I didn't quite understand the
objection but I will if if there was an
objection or yeah yeah I am trying to
sort of motivate the the problems that
could arise with depth if you do things
namely without any bells and whistles I
get to it so then what happens is that
at the end of the day what you can get
you can get a very small component here
and you end up getting a gradient that
has some of the components of it is gone
to zero with not zero and so it's very
hard to to do and run any optimization
algorithms as you can imagine if the
layers are long this problem could be
aggravated this is an algebraic point of
view for this for this problem but as a
scientific computing if you look at this
you can also look at it from a
geometrical point of view this could be
very well wrong but it's my intuition at
what this could happen geometrically and
that is you're probably dealing with the
problem that's very very ill condition
so in essence when you're computing the
gradient you have a whole lot of
jacobians that multiply each other and
at the end some directions get magnified
in some directions get smaller and
that's why your gradient loses component
in certain direction and gains
components significantly larger in
another direction so you can look at it
from the geometric and algebraic point
of view but you know people have
realized this as it was pointed out and
there are so many other ways that you
can get around this particular issue by
changing your activation function
instead of using the typical thing that
people used to do like the ten nature or
the sigmoid and now there are people who
work with the with the
gets around this issue of vanishing
gradient you can also try to come up
with careful initialization these you
can fine-tune the step size Bachelor
ization also more recently the the new
architectures like resonate and the
highway networks that get around us but
the common denominator on in all of
these remedies pretty much is that that
you look at the problem it manifests
some algebraic or geometric issues and
you try to mitigate those and the topic
they did so all of this was my
motivation I wasn't trying to say
whether it is the right way to do it or
wrong it's just that you know things
like that can happen so but ok so you
look at it as a geometric algebraic
point if you will come up with the
solution but the point is all these all
the there is to it are there are there
view points that we can take to study
the similar problem and the the thing
that wasn't known to me but became known
to me very recently is that yes you can
look at these issues in a randomized or
a statistical point of view and as a
result you can actually have some bit
with some more insight into what can go
wrong and to the best of my knowledge
this was first I recently pointed out by
these guys I think the paper was
published and I CML that they said that
you know forget about the vanishing
exploding gradient problems so on
there's another issue with the depth and
that is what you get a deeper net your
gradient actually behaves like white
noise which is in a statistical
statement there is no longer any you
know algebraic or geometrical notion to
it there's a caveat in here where the
the gradient is with respect to the
inputs so you know you can argue what
that even means but in the paper to say
because of these chain rules and so on
you can relate this to also the actual
gradient training where we're in a one
layer feed-forward Network the the
gradient of the output with respect to
the input actually has some sort of an
structure but as we increase the layers
to 24 you see that what we end up
getting is pretty much white noise
whereas the resonate maintain the
structure and the the the effect of the
losing the correlation
appears much less they also have very
interesting theory in which they show
that this is indeed true that the
correlation between the gradient
actually geometry goes to zero for the
feed-forward networks and for the
resonant actually it's gonna get better
and if you do batch normalization you
actually circumvent this problem
altogether so just looking at the
problem in a randomized way you all of a
sudden came up with a new problem that
didn't exist before and this is this was
very interesting to me and as a result
we sort of started to look at it in that
direction so we already knew the
algebraic geometric issues that can go
wrong exploding vanishing gradient
problems so on and so forth the
statistical randomized approach those
guys came up with a shattered gradient
problem and what we did was a leave you
the two guessed the acronyms but this is
the problem we came over caramelized
reduced anger problem and we came up
with this problem in the spirit of
giving everything sexy names these days
is not sexy but it's still like so so
the gradient of the output with respect
to the input so here the examples that
for example is on the on the slide is is
a network a consists of one input on
what output right just a scalar input
scalar output and they compute the
gradient and they arrange over all the
possible inputs in in an interval and
they they plot the what the gradient
that in the output would be yes and you
can think of this as sort of some kind
of a sensitivity of the network with
respect to the input where if I'm
changing a little bit here in the input
my network ends can sort of distinguish
between the inputs because it doesn't
bitman if you you know it doesn't behave
like complete white noise it doesn't
wash out the information indium
yeah yeah so that's also another caveat
which is just assuming you know
particular set of weights initialized
randomly yes exactly
I'll get to training at the very end if
I get a chance all right so we get to
crap with a okay and the goal of my talk
is that the deep forward networks are
are crappy and I'll go through this to
explain what this means we didn't put
the terminology crap in the paper
obviously because we weren't gonna get
accepted but I think we should have
because that would give citations what
does crap says the crap says that as the
depth increase something we call the
kernel eyes angles between the inputs go
to zero and I'll spend a few lectures to
describe what this graph this graph
means again caveat is only at
initialization but we're gonna relax it
at the very end alright let's just take
a step back and look at the very simple
case where the nonlinear activation
functions are actually linear right so
I'm not doing anything sophisticated
here it's just that I put an input in
the matrix in the in the network are x
bunch of matrices and I get a vector up
so there's no non-linearity this is very
familiar to a lot of people who have
done the Merkel linear algebra in fact
we saw a couple of talks in the morning
this resembles what happens in power
iteration or proud of subspace methods
right very simplified version is that
suppose you get two vectors you start
from two arbitrary vector no particular
assumptions about this at this stage if
I repeatedly apply matrix a to that
meter to the to each one of these in
separately and I keep repeating over and
over and over again
forget about the normalization and so on
and so forth because I only care about
the direction and if I do it long enough
I see that these vectors even though
they could have very well been you know
completely different directions they
actually end up pointing towards the
same direction or Oh parallel so they
lose this any
formation that was containing their
angle is completely lost and everything
that remains it just depends on the
magnitude the idea of what we have or
the crap is that this actually carries
over to deep feed-forward networks so
you we see there some some some
similarities in the it what happens in
the para duration into deep neural net
and the depth corresponds to the number
of these multiplications okay so let me
just quickly go through this so consider
this feed forward network one layer
multi-level perceptron if you will
inputs and end neurons right I can put
all of this in a vector so I will have
the output will be an n-dimensional
vector
I'll put X I get one vector I put Y I
get another vector I can seasonally just
look at their dot product like I can
look at the dot product of these outputs
and I can look at this dot product
beyond just being a scalar it also
encodes in it the angle of the output or
the angle of the input as he goes
through the transformation here governed
by the by the network well you know
things are much easier if you go
asymptotic so yes yes so suppose you
know you you send n to infinity and you
converge to do you have law of large
number and so on everything is nice and
you end up getting a something that you
can think of it as an inner product in a
feature space now I'm a little bit vague
here what does that even mean or but you
know you still get an inner product in
some kind of a Hilbert space you can
think of it if you will it's not really
a little relevant to what I'm gonna say
as a you know some kind of a reproducing
kernel Hilbert space got a unique kernel
so on and so forth but that's not the
focus on my talk even though that could
be something that one can can leverage
upon and maybe say something more but my
whole talk it relies on the fact that if
I for example look at the feature
transformations as being something like
this so I put that X into the network
and I end up getting a function I'm some
kind of a some kind of the hilbert space
now i can think of phi as a mapping that
sends every image in my net
work into a function so then the neural
net itself can be can be thought of as a
member of a hilbert space now I can
think of because I haven't met you know
Hilbert space I can work with it's got a
lot of structure I can work with you
know different notions that comes with
it such as angles and that's what we're
gonna do this idea is not ours by any
means this viewpoint a few years ago
this brilliant people came up with it
and it showed that if you wait sir
Gaussian and your Sigma or activist
[ __ ] rá Lu you get what's known as
the arc cosine kernel it can be written
like this that sends the angle at the
output as measured by the kernel - this
relates to the angle in the input and
this angle is just a good old good old
Euclidean angle so the first thing we
did in this paper was that to replace
calcium with all the rotational
invariant distributions and we showed
that the criminal stays the same now
what is an example of rotational
invariant beyond Gaussian you can think
of multivariate a distribution
multivariate Laplace and so on and so
forth so we augment a class you can also
think of the that kernel is a little bit
in more compact way as the expect or the
cross variance of of these two
transformations of a random variable
which is Gaussian whose covariance given
like this the details of this really
doesn't matter the point of that is that
you can extend these results to more
general weight weights they don't have
to be rotational invariant and but but
you lose this equality so now the
universal kernel was exactly our cosine
but in this case in more general weights
you get converges in distribution where
for any activation function as long as
they're well behaved in that sense and
you have a weight distribution that's
also got some finite moments and mean
zero as the M or the number of inputs go
I could affinity you actually end up
approaching the universal kernel this is
the lipid weak we can also get converges
in expectation for not every activation
function for these three classes that
are actually more relevant these day
anyways and under similar assumptions we
can get the
that the the actual kernel will converge
into the the arccosine kernel as the M
goes to infinity right well it's not I
don't know if no no ok so I listen if
this is doesn't say that it per se just
says that Azzam goes to infinity you can
always assign the kernel to this network
it just says that kernel approaches they
are quotes on kernel yeah okay so but
now let's look at the crap problem okay
so this is the leaky raloo if you will
is a generalization of riilu and just
plugging the the thing that we got for
the leaky raloo the the generalize
Universal course on kernel for that that
relates angle at the input to the angle
at the first layer but there is no
reason why you have to stop at the first
layer you can keep on going so nobody we
also look at the normalized camera
because I will get rid of the the
magnitudes I just want to look at angles
and I can recursively apply this sort of
a kernel and I get that at every layer I
can relate the Langille at that layer as
measured by Euclidean space and you
clean noted it to the next one and if I
do this repeatedly this is the result
that was interesting to me because what
it says is that for example in a leaky
relu or raloo as in a special case of it
actually this angle between the inputs
converges to zero as measured by this by
this but is kernel what does that mean
that means that regardless of how I want
to train again at initialization
regardless of how I what kind of image I
put at the beginning into my neural net
pretty much everything is lost nor like
completely becomes oblivious to the all
the information containing to the input
image the only thing that now at that
point moment sees it's just a magnitude
which is much smaller than when you can
think of angles and so on
even though a lot of these you know
could be just hey you say you have to
send anything to infinity or have
infinite number of neurons but the
central limit theorem kicks in pretty
quickly and you can just for a few
hundred neurons you can see that they
actually follow the theoretical curve
pretty pretty nicely so what this curve
is saying is that the blue and as we get
darker towards the red the number of
layers are increasing so one two four
eight sixteen and 128 and this new is
the degree of freedom of the
multivariate t distribution so it's one
example that we have we have other
examples as well and as you can see the
angle between the input and output
follows first of all the theoretical
result but also as the number of layers
increase you can see that everybody is
getting shifted up and it's approaching
the angle zero training I'll get to this
is like the section like a power
iteration so let me get to it so this
does not say that increasing layer is
bad it just says that in one thing that
definitively says is that increasing
layer and a random initialization makes
it a little harder to Train than than
just you know some careful
initialization for example this is only
at the but we've extended this actually
Russell has extended this let me let me
just finish this so the idea is that you
know it Maps all the inputs of similar
points remember it's it's a hilbert
space so angles matter the sort of point
maps into similar points as you relates
to they as it relates to angles again
that means all information is lost so
this is the key result or I have to say
that comes as a result of this is that
it's hard to train if you randomly
initialize that lease initially with the
width the depth okay so what does that
even mean to the another implication of
this is that the initialization that you
can go through similar arguments bubble
by come up with the result that you know
if I
my weights at least with the weights
that have variants like that I preserve
certain properties and the interesting
thing about this is that he actually
collapses to the case of the popular
initialization that people use for the
case of relu it collapses to what we
have for the case of leaky raloo if you
put a equals zero so it's a
generalization of that I'm not going to
go through this let me just because I'm
going to get running out of time it's
just now let me talk about the Train
right so not that those was just
initialization but training as you can
imagine training becomes extremely
difficult to answer any question because
you take one iteration of any
optimization algorithm you immediately
lose everything you had assumed about
your weights if you assume a idea you
lose that if you assume Gaussian you
lose that you lose every assumption that
you have now Russell has shown that in
fact it not all is lost there is still
some structure that's maintained even if
you start training as long as your
optimization algorithm satisfies a
certain property so I'm not going to do
exact details of the result but it will
be hopefully out next week or the week
after that like all the things on much
yeah
so what does it say it says for a
certain class of optimization procedures
such as SGD which is very popular they
maintain a certain invariance meaning
that the layer wise kernel actually
remains our cosine as a result the
kernel of the full network also remains
constant across an iteration so they're
invariant that we stay on the invariant
if you will paths as measured by these
are quotes on kernel whereas if you look
at Adam or rmsprop they have this tuning
parameter epsilon that you divide by and
it shows they chose that as the epsilon
changes there is actually very sharp
transition from where they their kernel
can be very well approximated but our
cosine to the point that the kernel is
no longer near being our course on in
fact they destroyed the horse symmetry
as measured by the or question so and
that you could you could argue that has
to do with sometimes Adam having a
better performance than SGD we don't
know that these are very poor
results another thing that's interesting
is that to relation between these and
what Michael is going to talk about as
well as the results of Peter Bartlett
that says you know you can measure the
complexity of network as it relates to
the to the covert to to the norm of the
weights and so on and so forth
yeah with that I stopped and I'm not
going to talk about the angles or the
direction as measured by this by the
action of neural net on it I mean you
obviously can look at it in any in a
Euclidean so this goes back to the
question that you asked earlier I'm not
saying that deep learning is a bad thing
I'm just saying if you have a deep
learning and you randomly initialize it
at the initial phase you're gonna have
issue because there's there is no
expressivity if you like left in the
network because it just jumbles
everything up and it doesn't care about
inputs anymore so you might take you a
long time before you can break this
symmetry to get to some point an SGD
might take a lot longer time because
it's invariant to these it stays
invariant to this kernel where else Adam
breaks this much quicker and you can
actually train with adam faster than
this gb this is the message I'm not
saying deep learning is bad the crap
only applies to the initialization they
can talk
yes sir